what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and like we talked about yesterday
Marvel Studios does seem to be making
some pretty big changes now these
changes are coming because Kevin feige
the president of Marvel Studios is
trying to make the MCU better which of
course everybody would love no matter
what side of the MCU you are on right
now whether you love it or don't like it
so much better is always good and Kevin
feige and current CEO of Disney Bob Iger
did say that they were going to try to
improve the quality of the content that
they put out and it looks like that is
exactly what they are doing yesterday we
talked about a really big change that
Marvel Studios made by getting new
writers for the King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars that used to be
Jeff loveness and Mike Waldron they are
no longer attached to those projects
Unfortunately they were both attached to
some projects like Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and Multiverse of Madness
that didn't do so well so it looks like
Marvel Studios decided to get New Riders
to make the future projects better let's
hope that works if you want to check out
all the details about that you can check
out our video from yesterday but today
it looks like Marvel Studios has made
even more changes to the MCU with a new
Rider that they hired for the
Thunderbolts after they got rid of the
last one and it does seem like Marvel
Studios really is in some sort of a
pattern right now and we'll break down
that pattern later on in the video but
this new Rider is affecting actually two
different movies and possibly a pretty
big way but don't worry of course we
will break it all down for you in this
video and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items as well we pick one winner at the
end of each month and the winner gets to
pick one item only a few days left now
for August so not too long ago Marvel
Studios got a new rider for the
Thunderbolts movie the movie that is
going to immediately follow up Captain
America Brave New World they now have
Lee sung Jin riding the Thunderbolts
whereas they had before Eric Pearson who
origin originally wrote The Black Widow
movie and again there's a big connection
we're gonna talk about here but we'll
get to that in a bit apparently some
writing for the Thunderbolts is going to
also be kind of affecting the plans that
Marvel Studios had for Captain America
4. but of course these moves are meant
to improve the quality of both of these
films that are going to be coming out
and Marvel seems to be doing something
very specific with getting these new
writers now Lee sung Jin is a different
type of writer but he does have a really
great track record with really great
shows that he's written before
definitely a different tone but he wrote
beef which is a series that came out
very recently that was very praised he
wrote 26 episodes of It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia a show that a lot of
people really like in the episodes that
he wrote were really good he's written
for shows like Two Broke Girls the show
Dave and for the people around my age
who know what the show is he wrote 24
episodes of Rob and Big basically he's
got the qualifications and he's got the
chops to be a great writer for the
Thunderbolts movie now apparently there
is a pretty big change coming to both of
the films Captain America Brave New
World and the Thunderbolts with this
change in writers this report comes from
Insider can we get some toast and they
State there was a plan to include Val
and Captain America Brave New World at
one point but after Thunderbolts got Lee
sung Jin as their new writer those plans
were scrapped also The Insider my time
to shine hello stated this the
Thunderbolts in Captain America 4 Brave
New World were more tightly connected
until Lee sung Jin came on board and
changed some plot elements so it seems
like some pretty decent changes were
made to the point to where it seemed
like Captain America 4 and the
Thunderbolts were almost going to be a
part 1 and part 2 movie and we do know
that they are going to still affect each
other in some way shape or form because
both are going to kind of deal with the
US government and kind of its corruption
at the moment Captain America Brave New
World is going to be dealing with
Thunderbolt Ross as the President of the
United States still trying to expand
experiment with super soldier serum and
the super soldier program also him
becoming the Red Hulk and the
Thunderbolts will deal with Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine who we've seen many
points in time now in the MCU assembling
the Thunderbolts team now can we get
some toast went on to State this unless
it's a post-credits scene Valentina de
Fontaine will not appear in Captain
America Brave New World when somebody
said that thou not being in Brave New
World was weird not really she's too
busy cleaning up her own messes so
clearly she has been going around
recruiting people as we've seen like in
the post-credit scene for Black Widow
and some things are apparently not going
according to her plan so she's gotta
clean up some of the messes with some
let's just call them bad guys that she's
tried to recruit and it looks like it
didn't work out for her in all cases
regardless it doesn't seem like it's
going to be too important that Valentina
show up in Captain America 4 and the
Thunderbolts we know she's going to be
in the Thunderbolts so not too much is
going to be affected but it does look
like they did have to change the story a
little bit because of the changes made
to the Thunderbolts but again hopefully
this is all for the better and like I
mentioned Marvel Studio seems to be
doing something very specific and that
is getting rid of writers that have
written movies or shows in the past that
didn't exactly go too well I'll explain
what I mean in just a bit but first big
thank you to comic book direct for
sponsoring this video they have created
a website and company that makes comic
book shopping the easiest it can
possibly be they deliver Comics straight
to your door you can get one-off Comics
or you can sign up for an entire run and
get a pretty big discount if you do so
and they'll ship the latest issue right
to your door each week they have the
latest from Marvel if you're trying to
keep up to date with all the recent
projects they have the latest from DC as
well and it's an all-in-one shop for
your Comics everything that you need in
one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below now as I mentioned at least
has replaced Eric Pearson as the writer
for the Thunderbolts and Eric Pearson is
who wrote The Black Widow movie and the
Black Widow movie wasn't really accepted
All Too Well among the fandom it wasn't
really viewed as a great movie in fact a
lot of fans complained about it and the
same thing goes for Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness a lot of fans
complained about these movies and kind
of basically said they weren't that good
so it's really interesting that Marvel
Studios has gotten rid of the writers on
upcoming projects like the Kang Dynasty
Avengers Secret Wars and the
Thunderbolts who wrote previous things
in the past again Jeff lubnis was going
to write Kang Dynasty he wrote
quantumania Michael Waldron was going to
write Secret Wars he wrote Multiverse of
Madness also he wrote Loki which was
fantastic and I do think he's a great
writer overall and would have done well
with Avenger Secret Wars but again it
looks like Marvel Studios kind of
connected some things here because the
same goes with Eric Pearson he wrote
black wedding and fans didn't really
like that movie that much so instead of
having him write the Thunderbolts they
got a new Rider it's definitely
unfortunate to hear about because of the
riders that were attached to these
projects and they very well could have
done a great job with the new projects
that they were going to write however
Marvel Studios is trying to change and
get better and this seems to be their
plan instead of having writers who wrote
previous projects in the past let's
bring on new ones let's try to have
something fresh and that brings up a
good point that Marvel Studios might not
have gotten rid of these writers because
they thought that they were bad but
simply because they needed a change they
needed something different than what's
been done before and based off of how
some fans have been complaining about
the MCU lately and how basically Kevin
feige and Bob Iger have acknowledged
that the quality hasn't really been
there lately this is a good plan switch
it up change it up make it fresh but do
it well you can't just change for the
sake of change you have to do it to
improve but it does sound like that is
what's happening especially with the big
changes in the Thunderbolts and
Valentina no longer being in Captain
America A Brave New World anymore
obviously Marvel Studios liked it enough
to make that a possibility Lee sung Jen
clearly came in with a new script and
Marvel Studios liked it and they said
you know what let's go ahead and make
those changes take Val out of Captain
America 4 and let's roll with this new
script so clearly they liked it they
liked it better than the first one
apparently so this is actually a good
sign and like I mentioned if Valentina
was going to be in Captain America 4 at
all before it was probably not that big
of a deal yes there was going to be more
connectivity that way but Captain
America Brave New World is supposedly
already going to be sort of a mini
Avengers film so we'll definitely feel
the connectivity in that film and
Thunderbolts is going to pick up where
Captain America 4 leaves off so we'll
fill the connectivity there as well so
overall I think this is a pretty good
change I think Marvel Studios trying to
switch it up and be fresh is good I
think they're going to try from here on
out to avoid using writers that they
have worked with in the past not because
they think they are bad but because they
are trying to go for something different
and I hope it works I truly do but let
me know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below you think this is a
good idea or do you think having writers
who worked on previous MCU projects is
actually a good thing because they might
feel more connected let us know all your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news and of course you
can always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf wolf
foreign